This episode of DNews is brought to you by
HARRY’S.
So, it's cold and flu season.
That sucks.
But whenever I feel crappy, I can't tell if
I've got the cold, or the flu -- does it matter?
What's the difference?!
When I get a cough, or a headache or whatever
for a few days, I always assume it will go
away, or that I just have a cold… but sometimes…
it's the FLU!
Even though the medicine says its for both
the cold and the flu, they're entirely different
viruses.
The common cold is caused by over 200 different
viruses!
Coronaviruses, rhinoviruses, metapneumoviruses,
enteroviruses and parainfluenza viruses all
make the short list; but they really are all
different.
This is why we can't "cure" the common cold.
The flu, on the other hand, is caused by influenza
viruses.
These respiratory viruses invade the body
and set up shop and cause very similar symptoms,
because the human body only has so many ways
to fight.
When your body is invaded by a virus, chances
are you'll get the same symptoms every time,
dry or sore throat, coughing and sneezing,
mild fever, congestion and maybe a headache.
Pretty standard stuff.
If it's REALLY bad, you'll get aches and pains
and exhaustion too.
This happens because your body is spending
resources fighting off the viral infection.
In general, flu is worse than the common cold,
the fever is higher, the aches and level of
exhaustion are more pronounced, and the cough
can be more intense.
While there's almost no way to tell the difference
between the two infections… colds tend to
produce a fever less than 101 (38C), affects
the throat and cause a runny nose.
The flu, affects the lungs and the joints
-- so you're likely to feel more achy than
leaky.
Telling the difference is one thing, but once
you're infected you only have a couple days
to get treatment.
After the first 48 hours, the infection has
usually stopped multiplying and is wreaking
havoc on the body instead.
Regardless, once symptoms start for viral
infections, there's no simple cure.
Antibiotics WILL NOT HELP, because they fight
BACTERIA not VIRUSES.
Taking an antibacterial drug during a viral
infection is pointless.
In fact, a lot of the remedies for colds and
the flu aren't really based on… well science.
Many people take vitamin C like it's going
out of style, but a study from the University
of Alberta looked at results and found there's
really no evidence that it helps.
Results suggest it MIGHT help with marathon
runners who have compromised immune systems
due to exhaustion, but even then it's a minor
help.
I like to take zinc when I'm starting to feel
ill, and science DOES support that.
Zinc is used by human immune cells as a catalyst,
so when you boost the amount of zinc your
immune cells can protect the body a bit better,
but too much can damage it -- so don't overmedicate.
In the end, a cold will persist for 10 days,
while some flu symptoms will persist for three
weeks; long after the influenza virus has
been eradicated.
If you REALLY want to avoid getting sick,
get a flu vaccination.
Only 30 percent of surveyed adults get vaccinated
year over year.
Flu vaccines are made every year by specialists
who use massive datasets to predict which
influenza viruses will dominate this season
-- see, there's more than one mutation, and
they vie for power and bodies to infect.
The 2014 flu vaccine will protect against
Influenza A H1N1 and H3N2, as well as a couple
influenza B viruses.
You might recognize H1N1, we're still seeing
that left over from 2009's unexpected flu
epidemic!
Crazy right?
So yes, there IS a difference between colds
and flu, but if you catch one of the over
200 viruses that cause these crappy feelings
the best way to handle it is to drink fluids
and help keep yourself hydrated and rest.
If you minimize nutritional strain on your
immune system by enjoying warm chicken soup
and let your immune system do it's work, you'll
be fine.
Empathy can also help, studies have shown
people who have families or even an empathetic
doctor recover faster than those who don't
so help out a friend if they're sick, but
don't catch it yourself.
If you insist on medication, decongestants
and antihistamines will treat the symptoms
of both cold and flu, but again -- don't take
antibacterial meds unless you know it's a
bacterial infection -- that's something a
doctor can tell you.
And speaking of stuff you keep in the medicine
cabinet, if you’re looking for a good razor
to shave with try Harry's!
Harry's was started by a couple guys who liked
shaving so much that bought a razor factory
to make their own.
They're cheap, they show up at your door,
and they're sharp both in look and… well,
sharpness.
Just go to Harrys.com and use the promo code
DNews to save $5 off your first order AND
you’ll be supporting the show.